alors doc gynéco comment ça va toucher
divers qui vont choisir mais non quoi il
ya du vrai et akena le plus clé alors
ben si tu sais quoi on est on est au bar
et tumorales
qu'est ce que je peux vous servir l
intérêt qu on ne sait jamais vais aussi
vite mais tue boit cul sec à mon avis ce
qui est rouge ça fait rire faux mails à
l'eva dit autant que je sache je ne sens
pas ça c'est à mon avis et d'huile ouais
je ne prends pas ça arrive a dit prendre
et moi je servais grange prend son nom
cette nuit il attend aussi fluide
c'est le but
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
[Musique]
pour son goût du cocasse est là où
s'amorce et à lui n'est pas dit si mme
dans la boîte
c'est du vide et que ça fera à l'est ont
baissé du québec allez merci radio d'oc
oui alors